today on the matt walsh show with the
death of queen elizabeth the left has
taken the opportunity to rant about the
evils of colonialism but there is one
form of colonialism still happening in
the world today and it is left-wing
ideological colonialism we'll talk about
that also podcast movement finally
issues an apology for calling ben
shapiro's physical presence harmful
local politicians at dc panic as illegal
immigrants are shipped to their
uh alleged sanctuary city morning joe
tries its hand at biblical exegesis and
it doesn't go well in our daily
cancellation we'll deal with a few
recent attempts by the left to finally
answer the great question of our time
all of that and more today on flannel
friday
[Applause]
[Music]
when running a business you'll get hit
with all kinds of interesting scenarios
like
what are meal and break requirements
that i must provide for employees how do
i handle an employee doesn't show up to
work how do i improve company culture
and employee engagement one complaint
can destroy your entire company the
problem is though hr managers who are
meant to navigate this stuff are
expensive they can easily cost over 80
000 per year but with bambi you get
access to your own dedicated hr manager
starting at just 99 a month all of
bambi's hr managers are based in the
united states and can support the
nuances across all 50 states your
manager is available by phone email
real-time chat to help you effortlessly
run employee onboardings and
terminations encourage good performance
and make sure that your business stays
compliant with ever-changing hr
regulations with bambi's hr autopilot
you can automate the most important hr
practices like setting policies training
and feedback in fact bambi clients are
four times less likely to have a
complaint filed against them so go to
bambi.com right now and type in matt
walsh under podcast when you sign up
it'll really help the show as well
spelled b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com
bambi.com type in matt walsh
queen elizabeth who of course passed
away yesterday at the age of 96 after
reigning for 70 years was one of the
last great leaders and public figures in
the world she possessed virtues like you
know grace nobility dignity stoicism
these are all character traits
especially those last two um which have
all but vanished from public life
instead in their place western nations
in particular find themselves led by
boorish morons self-centered ignoramuses
and petulant crybabies and that pretty
much sums them all up what's more we're
a civilization which denies its history
and makes war against its own traditions
that's another reason to mourn the
queen's passing she was uh an
anachronism but i mean that in a
positive way a link to the past a
reminder of how things used to be
but are no longer
and it's possible to appreciate all of
that even if you like me don't have any
particular fascination with the royal
family and even if you like me are
actually a bit perplexed by the
fascination um i don't spend a lot of
time thinking about british royalty but
when it comes to queen elizabeth
i can appreciate these facts about her
of course we live in a different world
now it's a world where people are
eager to advertise their utter lack of
dignity and of grace uh it's almost a
virtue to not possess those things
and there have been many such displays
in in response to a queen elizabeth's
death like that from ujju anya professor
of uh this is what she's a professor of
blackness and multilingualism at
carnegie mellon university
and there carnegie mellon you can spend
60 000 a year to study utterly useless
subjects while having your brain
assaulted and your soul pummeled by
hateful rabid ideologues like professor
ujju who reacted to the queen's imminent
death on thursday before she had died
with this tweet i heard the chief
monarch of a thieving raping genocide
genocidal empire is finally dying
may her pain be excruciating
now the professor issued more tweets
doubling down on this sentiment she
feels absolutely morally justified in
wishing excruciating pain on a dying
elderly woman
because that dying elderly woman has
committed the crime of being powerful
and also white which is the greatest
crime of all cbs news correspondent
wesley lowery was uh not quite as
aggressive but he had similar feelings
tweeting
the death of a person seen as a near
deity by the white political ruling and
media class but who was also at one
point the oppressive ruler of something
like 30 percent of the global population
is going to provide an excellent example
of the subjectivity of straight news
reporting
there was much discussion about
colonialism with uh many echoing the
thoughts of german comedian
kunk who wrote
dear white europeans you do realize that
black people won't mourn when another
colonizer dies she's old enough
finally let her and the whole colonial
system go in peace
there are american media figures like
eugene scott and jamil hill jamil hill
who agreed that now is the right time to
talk about the sins of colonialism
scott tweeted real question for the now
is not the appropriate time to talk
about the negative impact of colonialism
crowd
when is the appropriate time to talk
about the negative impact of colonialism
hill had her own answer to that question
she said journalists are tasked with
putting legacies into full context so
it's entirely appropriate to examine the
queen and her role in the devastating
impact of continued colonialism
now it's of course
absurd to call queen elizabeth's impact
on the world devastating she has in fact
been resisting tyranny literally since
she was a teenager
um enlisting in the military during
world war ii at the age of 19. the royal
family chose not to flee to canada even
as the germans bombed london and
elizabeth herself contributed to the war
effort as soon as she was old enough to
do so
as far as colonialism goes
the sort of historical colonialism that
the left laments and has used queen
elizabeth's death as a forum to whine
about
was neither all good nor all bad
i mean you can no more condemn all
colonialism
than you can condemn all war terrible
atrocities occur in times of war but so
do acts of heroism and sacrifice
there are wars waged for good reasons
and bad reasons and many other wars
whose motivations fall somewhere in
between
in the case of colonialism
the fact remains that from a broad
historical perspective
western civilization and its freedoms
and luxuries and rights and comforts and
benefits
would not exist without it
now the left would probably agree with
that sentiment but then they would claim
that well that's proof
that the west is inherently evil
and yet those same people choose to live
here even so feasting on the fruits of a
tree which they claim is evil at its
root
which only goes to show that judging the
impact of so-called colonialism is not
nearly as simple as its critics pretend
it has had many effects that they
themselves enjoy
if not appreciate
the discussion about colonialism also
ignores the fact that there were empires
all across the globe and all throughout
history who practiced their own version
of it
the whole world was shaped this way and
if colonialism is an abject
straightforward evil which i deny and if
we can inherit
its guilt through our blood you know
which i also deny
we would all share that guilt
to the point where it makes no sense to
dwell on it
but here we are again talking about
historical colonialism
and that's the kind that no longer
exists
there is however another form of the
practice the modern form and the irony
is that the people who spend the most
time screaming about the colonialist
practices of 70 years ago or 300 years
ago
have nothing at all to say about the
sort of colonialism perpetrated by
western cultures today in fact if they
do have anything to say about it they
will speak up in defense of it
that's because the only sort of
colonialism still carried out by western
nations in modern times is left-wing
ideological colonialism historical
colonial colonialism had its bad moments
this
left-wing ideological version on the
other hand is all bad through and
through
it is the attempt to export
by force blackmail bribery political
pressure or other forms of coercion
left-wing cultural ideas and priorities
to people and cultures and countries
that do not want them
it just so happens that cnn only a few
days ago provided us with a striking
example of just this sort of thing
cnn anchor christiaan amanpour had an
interview with william ruto who is the
president-elect of kenya now i didn't
initially see the clips of this
interview online i only became aware of
the exchange because the sweet baby gang
in kenya which is uh it turns out a
sizable community
i'm pleased to to discover uh they they
watched it and they alerted me to it and
i i i'm glad they did because
this whole exchange especially in light
of this colonialism conversation is
quite instructive watch
i want to talk to you about a specific
you know human rights situation in parts
of africa and including in your own
country you yourself gained worldwide
attention a few years ago when you said
there was quote no room for
homosexuality in kenyan society i want
to know whether you still stand by that
we have
um kenyan
law we have kenyan constitution
we have our tradition we have our
customs
we will continue to respect
other people's customs
as they respect our customs and our
tradition i
am very clear i am very clear that
we respect everybody and what they
believe in
but we also have what we believe in
and
we expect to be respected for what we
believe in
so before i ask you to flesh that out
and what exactly does it mean i want to
play you
what president kenyatta said to me
about this issue i will not engage in a
subject that is of no
it's uh it is not of any major
importance to the people and the
republic of kenya this
is not an issue as you would want to put
it
of a
human right to this
this is an issue of society
of our own
base as a culture as a people
regardless of which community
you come from
this is not acceptable this is not
agreeable
now what we've seen
here so far are two leading figures in
kenya trying to explain
kenyan culture to an outsider they're
both quite patient and gracious which
doesn't surprise me at all based on my
own experience in the country you know i
went there with my own very stupid
questions much like the stupid questions
amanpour is asking and everyone i talked
to was very kind and accommodating in
spite of how idiotic the line of
questioning was
but amenport continues to press the
issue uh so let's keep watching
so he's basically saying homosexuality
is not agreeable you've just said
that you're kind of trying to thread the
needle that the law says one thing but
you respect everybody's rights
will a ruto administration crack down
like many other leaders in africa on the
homosexual lgbtq community or will you
allow them their human rights and their
civil rights
i think
on that subject president kenyatta was
spot on
we do not want to create a mountain out
of a mall here
this is not a big issue for the people
of kenya
when the people when it becomes a big
issue for the people of kenya the people
of kenya will make a choice
as it is now
we are grappling with
five million young people who do not
have jobs
four million people who are hungry and
that is my concern
that is the focus of the people of kenya
at the moment when the issue you have
discussed about homosexuality
and the rights of lgbt will come
the people of kenya will make a choice
and we will respect
the choice of the people of kenya for
now
christian amanpour
let us focus on the real issues that
affect
our people as you know mr president with
respect these are real issues that
affect so many people around the world
but we will hold you to what you said
and we'll come back to you um if the if
the situation requires it which problem
probably it will
well watch out uh kenya christian
amanpour she's gonna hold you to this
and she's going to tell you what issues
matter to your country now i think mr
ruto was was very clear in his response
leaving no room for confusion but for
the benefit of christian amanpour i will
summarize first of all as both ruto and
kenyatta try to explain kenyan culture
doesn't
recognize any sort of inherent human
right to have whatever kind of sex you
want to have now
it may seem
unthinkable
to the modern western mind
that kenyans don't believe in that kind
of right that is the right to have sex
however you want
it might be unthinkable you may not be
able to get your mind around it
it may shock you and offend you
but that's the reality
you know in fact
very few cultures in the world or in the
history of the world recognize that
right the right to sex
is a very modern
very very western construct we just came
up with it last tuesday basically and
the rest of the world doesn't feel any
particular urgency to adopt it
themselves they just don't
that's it
second even more to the point the entire
issue is not relevant to kenyan society
there are millions of people in kenya
living in abject poverty starving to
death people don't have enough food to
eat families who live in shacks made out
of spare sheet metal and who if they
become ill could only go to a hospital
in a shack similar to the one they live
in except with the word hospital spray
painted and graffiti on the side
now not all of kenya looks like that but
it's a reality for a large portion of
the country so they're not worried about
lgbt issues they're not worried about a
lot of the issues that we're worried
about here because they don't have the
luxury or the time to worry about it
now
routeau is trying his best to
communicate this
if he were less patient if he were more
like me he would have simply shouted hey
lady our people are starving to death we
don't have time for this now piss off
and leave me alone you weirdo
but this is how ideological colonialism
works the leftist colonizer demands that
her values must be adopted by people and
cultures thousands of miles away she
insists that societies
she has no stake in and countries she
has never even visited must conform
themselves to her own proclivities
she demands that people she doesn't know
and has never met or even shared a
continent with must adopt and live by
her list of priorities and she does all
this while also claiming by the way to
be an advocate for democracy
well you just heard the answer there
well people of kenya will decide and if
we decide that we care about this issue
then we'll care about it and if not we
don't
i mean if you believe in democracy then
that should be a good answer for you but
apparently not
this is the official policy not just of
nosy journalists like amanpour but of
the american government
which is why we we gallivant across the
globe waving the rainbow flag in
everybody's face
meanwhile the very people demanding
ideological conformity from foreign
cultures also claim to be advocates of
multiculturalism
that's all the ruse as we have seen they
don't want multiculturalism
not anywhere close to that
they want unit culturalism okay they
want one culture one society one set of
priorities adopted by people of
different races and ethnicities all
across the world
that's what they want their ultimate
vision of diversity and multiculturalism
is a room full of people of varying skin
pigmentations and ethnic backgrounds all
speaking in unison reading off of a
script written by their left-wing
overlords
that's colonialism
that's what it looks like in the modern
world
and it is in many ways far worse than
any form of colonialism that came before
it
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
have you noticed that big tech companies
today are masquerading as privacy
companies big tech literally feeds on
your information like parasites sure
maybe they'll release a feature now and
then that does some good but collecting
and selling off your data is big tech's
that's their mo it's in their nature
they can't stop themselves from looking
at what you do online to protect myself
then against big tech's prying eyes i
use expressvpn when you use expressvpn
uh on your computer or front you're
hiding your unique ip address websites
can't use that address to find out your
real location or track what you do
online expressvpn encrypts and reroutes
100 of your online activities so your
internet provider wi-fi administrator
and uh hackers can't see it at all and
expressvpn is incredibly easy to use it
takes just one click to protect all of
your devices one expressvpn subscription
covers up up to five devices at the same
time so you can protect your entire
family at the same time that's why
expressvpn is rated number one by cnet
wired techradar and countless others get
the vpn that i trust to protect my
online privacy from big bad tech visit
expressvpn.com walsh and you can get an
extra three months free on a one year
package that's
vpn dot expessvpn.com welsh
expressvpn.com
walsh to learn more
well happy flannel friday everybody this
for now is the compromise we have
reached after weeks of intense
negotiations the pro-flannel and
anti-flannel factions
on the verge of violent hostilities
we're able to come to this tenuous
peace agreement
wherein i will wear
my flannels on friday
but
what i want you to know is that
this is not just for me okay that's this
is you know i tell you my vision
is that flannel friday will not be just
me this is for the whole sweet baby gang
this is for
uh indeed the whole world
to take part in
i want uh flannel friday to be to be
something that we can all
take part in and enjoy i hope that it
stands as a symbol
of unity and peace for the entire globe
so we should all wear our flannels on
fridays and tell our friends
and our families about it and tweet
about it with hashtag flannel friday and
shout from the rooftops and the rafters
because flannel friday is a movement
ladies and gentlemen
what the hell am i babbling about
it's another good question
here's an update um on something we just
talked about in the opening monologue
there's there's a little bit more to
this story from the daily wire says
carnegie mellon university condemned a
professor on thursday who called for the
death of queen elizabeth to be
excruciatingly painful uh saying that
the professor's tweet was offensive and
objectionable
um and then so we know we read what
she's uh what she tweeted already
at the university said in a statement
we do not condone the offensive and
objectionable messages posted by ujoo
anya today on her personal social media
account free expression is core to the
mission of higher education however the
views she shared absolutely do not
represent the values of the institution
nor the standards of discourse we seek
to foster
now
that's all nice and good and um
these days it's like somewhat impressive
that they at least did that much because
we know that usually there's no
accountability whatsoever for anybody on
the left they can say whatever they want
so they condemned it and they condemned
it and they they you know even by name
fine
but really what they should be doing we
should not be satisfied with this we
should be what we should be demanding
and i know some people are demanding and
their right to demand it is that she be
fired
okay yes it's you want to call it's
right-wing cancel culture sure whatever
you want to call that sure yeah she
should be canceled absolutely
you're a professor
okay it's not like she works at walmart
or something like that she's a professor
which means that she's in charge of
educating people and uh and this is the
kind of thing that she's saying publicly
it's an embarrassment
to the institution that you work for
and it would make any
thinking person very hesitant to send
their kids to that
institution like these are the kinds of
i'm going to spend
60 000 a year to for my kids to be
taught by people like this
and by the way i didn't even read i mean
i could go down she wasn't just that
tweet that she was it wasn't just just
that like i said she doubled down on it
and she was responding to people
criticizing her in very vulgar
disgusting ways
that uh i can't even read to you but you
can go look it up if you want to
this woman is like she she has the the
the maturity of a of a 12 year old
and um
you know a moral insight much worse than
that so
it would make sense for the institution
to fire her
that's what they ought to do
people like this should lose their jobs
and we shouldn't be hesitant or shy
about calling for that but you know lest
we be accused of canceled culture or
anything else
um
kind of on the same subject here this on
the daily wire says the uh
the media trade association that
vilified ben shapiro last month for
simply appearing at a recent trade show
apologized on thursday saying its
treatment of the daily wire star wasn't
right
podcast movement the industry's biggest
trade group and host of annual
conferences that bring together top
media companies
said in a statement that it was wrong to
claim that shapiro's presence at its
recent dallas show caused harm
the mayor culpable came after the daily
wire immediate giant cumulus both vowed
to end their support for the
organization
so the statement said
as we stated we're continuing to
evaluate our priorities policies uh
rather guiding social media and events
with inclusivity diversity and respect
for all
we have to start by sincerely
apologizing to mr shapiro for our
reaction when he visited a booth that we
that we sold his company that wasn't
right podcast movement began in 2014
with four podcasters who had an idea to
create a vibrant community that was for
podcasters by podcasters we're still
those people with the same idea and
recognize there's work to do as we grow
the wire co-founder jeremy boring who uh
at the company's recent backstage event
had blasted podcast movement for
unadulterated bigotry
said uh people rarely admit when they do
wrong particularly on the left where
every cultural indicator reinforces your
error podcast movement did the right
thing with this apology co-founder dan
franks also called me to make clear
their treatment of ben was unacceptable
good on them
jeremy's being very gracious here
uh i am
a slightly less gracious person in
general so
yeah it's an apology it's it's the right
thing to do so you know kind of like
carnegie mello melon responding
to their professor and the horrible
thing she said yeah it's the right thing
to respond to it
but you know it's to me it's not quite
enough
and especially with podcast movement
yeah they they gave the apology this is
like two weeks later three weeks like
two weeks later
and they're only doing it because they
had no other choice i mean they tried
everything they could to avoid
apologizing
but then once cumulus got on board
and there were more companies you know
having our back on this thing as they
should that podcast moving they'll say
well what choice do they have
if you want to have a podcast conference
a podcast organization and you lose
daily wire and you lose cumulus you
start you start losing
all of the biggest podcasting companies
well then you can't then your company is
gone
so they have no choice and they and they
very begrudgingly
finally apologized as an act of sheer
self-preservation
fine
i'm glad they did
but um
i am certainly not at all convinced that
this was uh that this was
something that they did because they
really feel that that they were wrong
and and uh they're trying to make amends
or whatever
all right let's go to this um
another report from the daily watchers a
sitting member of the washington dc city
council blamed texas and arizona
thursday for an influx of immigrants
stressing washington's social services
dc councilwoman
brianne nadeau pointed the fingers at
the figure at the two border states both
run by republican governors claiming
that they turned washington into a
border town god forbid let's listen to
some of that
it's been said but it's worth
reiterating that the governors of texas
and arizona have created this crisis
and the federal government has not
stepped up to assist the district of
columbia so we um along with our
regional partners will do what we've
always done we'll rise to the occasion
we've learned from border towns
like el paso and brownsville
and in many ways
the governors of texas and arizona
have turned us into a border town we
don't know how long this will take
to resolve we don't know how long they
will continue busing and so the right
thing to do here is to be prepared to
ensure we can greet every bus we can get
people off on the right foot we can get
them where they want to go
and that will ultimately help them
oh god forbid they turned us into a
border town
we don't want to be one of those
now of course that's not even close to
true i don't have the numbers in front
of me but you can fact check me on this
and i i i'm quite certain in saying
that the influx of um illegal immigrants
to
washington dc
um
or to any of the other cities where
they're being shipped off to chicago it
doesn't even come close doesn't even
because it's barely a fraction of what
actual border towns are dealing with
you know like a tenth or less than that
so no they they haven't been turned into
a border town
um if they think it's bad now
okay
then if they were actually turned into
but if they had to deal with the flow of
illegal immigrants anywhere near the
scale that really that actual border
towns have to deal with it then they
would be they'd be panicking much more
than they are now
but as i as i said when a couple days
ago we were listening but i think it was
the
i think that yeah it was the mayor of
chicago lightfoot
complaining about governor abbott for
sending
illegal immigrants to her even though
they opened their arms and they said
we're a sanctuary city
all that texas and arizona are doing is
saying well you're a sanctuary so don't
you want you said you're a sanctuary
don't you
so we're we're sending people to the
sanctuary that you've set up
oh oh well you don't actually want them
though so you wanted you wanted the
virtue signal you want to be able to say
that about yourself
you wanted to be able to say we're a
sanctuary city without actually having
to
deal with the everyday reality
and all of the challenges and problems
not to mention crime that comes with it
when you have all these people being
shipped to you right i get it now
this is how the ruling regime works
this everything about this perfectly
illustrates leftist elites and how they
function
where they want to be able to
stand off at a distance
and
make proclamations
and suggest policies impose policies
that are utterly disastrous catastrophic
and cause untold human misery but they
don't want to have to experience any of
that
so they're they're this is this is left
wing compassion for you left-wing
compassion is
um
that
they support
actions
that cause suffering that they don't
have to experience
their compassion is forcing you to be
compassionate
it's like coming up with things that
they think a compassionate person should
do and forcing you to do it because
they're not going to do it
right the compassionate the right
compassionate thing is to defund the
police to get rid of law enforcement to
stop enforcing
the law to let
criminals out of jail
that's the compassionate thing and so
they're going to do that in especially
in neighborhoods and towns where they
don't live
but they're in their gated communities
and they've got armed security and all
the rest of it
but that of course is not compassion i
mean true compassion you know what
compassion means
compassion is um if you follow the
etymology of the word actual meaning of
the word
uh it means to it means you know
co-suffering is what it means
compassion co-suffering so
when you're compassionate
you are
uh taking on the suffering
of
someone else you are taking part in
yourself you're suffering alongside them
you're relieving their suffering and
taking some of it upon yourself
that's why as christians we would say
the the ultimate act of compassion in
human history was jesus christ dying on
the cross taking on
the suffering of all mankind caused by
our sin um
that's why we call it the passion of the
christ right
but that's what compassion is and and
that's what we're all called to do on a
much smaller scale
but that means that you're doing it
okay but you yourself are taking on that
suffering
but if you're calling for a policy or
for something to happen
and uh and hoping that all the suffering
is felt by people who are not you then
by definition that is not
compassion
that actually is the that's indifference
which is essentially the opposite
speaking of uh the bible and and jesus
here's morning joe offering some
insightful
exegesis uh of of his own let's listen
to that
as a southern baptist that grew up
reading the bible maybe a backslidden
baptist but i still know the bible jesus
never once talked about abortion never
once and it was happening
back in ancient times it was happening
during his time never once mentioned it
for people perverting the gospel of
jesus christ down to one issue
it's heresy
go if you don't believe me if that makes
you angry why don't you do something you
haven't done in a long time open the
bible open the new testament read the
red letters you won't see it
there
and yet there are people who are using
jesus as a shield to make ten-year-old
rape girls go through a living and
breathing hell here on earth they've
also conveniently overlooked the parts
of the new testament where jesus talks
about
taking care
of the needy taking care of those who
are helpless who live a hopeless life
because they believe
these state legislators believe that
life begins at fertilization and ends at
childbirth and catty
what a powerful message yesterday
yes uh powerful just a a powerful straw
man there every single part of that was
a straw man
and
you know leftists they really think that
they're onto something here they always
think that this is a
this is
some sort of gotcha oh you see jesus
doesn't mention abortion there you go
a couple points about that
um
first of all abortion
is
the killing of innocent human life
and the bible does in fact forbid that
um forbids that all across the old and
new testament
forbids in the ten commandments
jesus forbids it okay these things are
explicitly forbidden
violence against the innocent harming
the innocent actually what jesus says is
that any and he specifies it for
children too he says that that if you're
going to harm a child it'd be better for
you to have a millstone hung around your
neck and to be drowned in the sea
okay that's how strong jesus felt about
it
one of the many statements that if jesus
had never said that
and uh and and and or even though he had
like if you
still if if today if a christian goes
around speaking in in terms as strong as
that they'll be accused well that's
unchrist-like
you're saying that it'd be better for
someone to have a stone hung around
their neck and be drowned in the sea
that's that's violent and terrible and
uncut
no it's literally christ-like because
that's literally what he said
and it is literal like it would be
better for you
if you're going to harm a child it would
actually be better for you to just drown
yourself
so yes both
the bible
forbids
abortion broadly speaking and so does
jesus because it because uh
harming the innocent is forbidden now
does it specify that is there any point
where it says hey by the way to all you
modern readers uh when we say don't kill
innocent people we include babies in
that no it doesn't say that
um it shouldn't need to say that in fact
it doesn't
when we are forbidden from murdering it
it rarely specifies
groups of people because we're supposed
to understand that it applies to
everyone
okay it also doesn't say that it says
don't murder people it never says that
you can't murder
a middle-aged woman
or a teenage boy
or someone who's 90 years old
it never specifies any stage of human
development or any age group
because it applies to all of them
and if you're not brain dead you should
already know that like it should be you
shouldn't have to ask the question if
somebody says to if god says to you as
he says to us in scripture uh don't
murder people
you shouldn't need the follow-up
question of oh sorry uh lord does that
include babies
are they oh we can't murder them either
okay thanks
did you really need that specified for
you
but here's the other problem if if you
need
if you need these
kinds of very specific
rules laid out for you
or if you think that jesus was supposed
to specifically mention every issue that
we deal with today
um well that's a problem for the left
isn't it because especially if they want
to bring the bible up i mean once again
what have i told you before
when the bible is brought into a
discussion about abortion especially it
is
9 times out of 10 or maybe 9.9 times out
of 10
someone on the left who brings it up
so they are the ones constantly bringing
religion and the bible and jesus into
not just the abortion conversation but
any conversation about a social issue
they constantly bring that in and then
they accuse us
of basing our entire uh
point of view on the bible and religion
well you're only saying that because of
the bible you're only saying that
because of religion so
you know
on one hand we only we only are saying
this because we're following the bible
as if that would be a bad thing anyway
but then on the other hand the bible
doesn't say that
it's very confused
but the point is this um the left tells
us that
trans people have always existed you
know transgenderism the fact that we're
seeing this skyrocketing rise and
transgender identification in modern
times that's not a it's not
that's not any social contagion it's not
because people are being indoctrinated
or groomed or anything like that they
claim
it's because well this many trans people
have always existed it's just that they
were you know they hadn't um
they didn't feel comfortable identifying
themselves as such
well it means that trans people existed
in jesus time and yet jesus never says
anything about trans rights
never says anything about it
actually one of the very first things
we're told in the bible is that god
created us male and female
there's no mention of any other category
there's no indication anywhere that a
man can be a woman
so by
by joe scarborough's logic trans writes
out the window jesus never says it
you know what else he doesn't mention
doesn't mention gay rights
quite the opposite actually
and he also jesus also never mentions
plenty of things that we should all
agree are bad like
he never specifically condemns slavery
as an institution he never specifically
condemns
child pornography or rape now
does that mean that we as christians
should endorse all of those things or be
indifferent or not have an opinion
doesn't mean that jesus endorsed them
no obviously not
because jesus didn't come to earth to
just provide a list of every single bad
thing we shouldn't do
but we are given commandments and
principles
and moral teachings
which we are then supposed to apply to
all of these
situations and all of these issues
and if you take the moral teachings that
we are given by jesus and you apply them
to
slavery child pornography rape
you can easily see that according to
these principles those things are
horrific evils
we also recognize it as a matter of
natural law we inherently recognize it
it's written on our heart
and the same thing goes for abortion
all right
maybe we'll do one more
thing here if i can
scroll down to it
okay this is important so the new
pinocchio movie starring tom hanks comes
out uh today i believe and it's actually
the second pinocchio film of the year
for some reason they make there's been
like 46 versions of this story put the
film
this one stars tom hanks produced by
disney
and it's essentially a shot-for-shot
remake of the disney cartoon version
except
this one is live action live action
except for pinocchio himself of course
is still like a cartoon because
they couldn't find a live-action uh
talking puppet who moves on its own
anyway it's getting trashed by critics
30 some percent critic rig critic rating
on rotten tomatoes the audience hates it
too
um the audience reviews aren't much
better total thrashing across the board
uh we haven't yet been told that it's
because of racism but i'm waiting for
that to happen
because i think there is they did add
they did add a black character into the
film like a character that didn't even
exist it wasn't just
changing one of the characters to make
them black but they added a character i
think in this version of pinocchio a
black woman
who appears and pops up throughout
and so
maybe that will be their excuse once
this thing does terribly and everyone
hates it they're going to say oh it's
only because of racism because you
didn't like that character
the review in the telegraph gives it one
star reading some of it says when gus
van sant directed a shot by shot replica
of psycho in 1998 the exercise was
widely decried as a cash-in perhaps it
if he'd waited 20 more years he would
have been hailed as a marketing genius
disney's latest live-action remake of a
classic from the studios animation vault
even looks like a business calculation
before you press play rather than
playing in theaters it's going straight
online as a free to view enticement to
disney plus subscribers
the company has been criticized for
releasing films directly onto their
streaming service the share hawkish
expediency of it seemed to reduce the
ravishingly crafted likes of pixar soul
and turning red to mere time passing
content but content is the only
appropriate term for this garish
dead-eyed exercise which recreates the
1940 masterpiece largely seen foreseen
albeit with a handful of instantly
forgettable minor detours
peanut pinocchio is now assisted on and
off by a young female puppeteer slash
ballerina for instance presumably to
help redress the story's gender uh
balance so i think that's the black
character that was added in
which means that this review is horribly
racist you have to like the film now
but here's the point i bring this up
because um i really think that this is
the worst thing disney is doing right
now
and
maybe the best argument for ditching
disney and
all of these
movie studios
it's well it's not quite as bad as the
woke stuff and child grooming but it's
it's pretty bad and it's all connected
anyway because the whole point or part
of the point of these remakes is to
wokify the films they're they are
corrections they're correctives taking
out the quote-unquote problematic
aspects of the stories and replacing it
with something that is more palatable
for modern people
but even without the woke stuff it's
still just an abomination i mean disney
is so bereft
of ideas so totally devoid of creativity
that now they're simply going through
their old catalog and producing the
exact same films again
except this time without the charm or
originality or personality it's not even
a remake you think of a remake you think
of uh well taking a film and we're going
to tell the same basic story but it's
going to be our it's going to be a new
take on an old story that's what a
remake is
and in that sense a lot of these old
classic disney films were already
remakes because they were taking stories
that already existed and had been
told in different versions sometimes for
centuries and they were kind of giving
their spin on it
but that's not what this is this is just
like a a total absolute recreation of
what already existed except without any
originality no personality
this is what happens when art is dead in
a culture what you're left with are
these lifeless
hollow recreations
and the premise is ridiculous
like oh let's
let's do a live-action version
as if as if the lack of realism in the
first version was a problem
no it wasn't i mean it's it's actually
absurd to do a realistic version
of a movie about a puppet who comes to
life or a realistic version about a
version of a movie about
a singing mermaid or a blue genie who
lives in a lamp
let's have that but make it realistic
this time
think about the lion king remake
which i think the lion king we make is
maybe hollywood's greatest abomination
of all time
is it you're taking this this cartoon
that was only that only came out you
know 20 years ago 25 years ago
calling it a live action remake which of
course it isn't because they're still it
still is starring talking lions and
there are no real ones so it's still
animation but we're going to take this
cartoon
and we're going to do it again shot for
shot and it's still going to be a
cartoon but this time it's going to look
realistic
except that now now you've got realistic
looking lions going around singing and
talking to each other it just looks what
before was was cute and creative and had
charm and personality now just looks
weird and awkward
and bizarre
so the cartoon is part of the art
and so what they're saying now is well
let's let's do it again without the art
let's let's have
let's try this piece of art but take out
the art
and see what happens
what you're left with is something
totally
empty and
[Music]
lifeless
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
johnny walker says matt makes great
points about holding companies
accountable that's why the dw doesn't
use youtube or twitter that's why matt
and shapiro don't have twitter pages you
guys use those tools to get large and a
lot of us have no other options if we
want to do something similar to what dw
does
i don't use a lot of these companies
that express views like this but when
you turn around and see large
conservative companies using them while
telling us not to
what is a woman was great there's
nothing offensive in there except for
the people you interview who are hard to
stomach well i've actually never said
that you shouldn't use twitter or
youtube or facebook or instagram or
whatever
i i have said the opposite pretty
consistently i think that if you can use
those platforms
to amplify a message of truth and
rationality
and uh morality if you can do that
then absolutely you should
um
use the platforms to undermine the
ideological agenda
of the people who run them
i think that's a
that's a good thing to do we should be
doing that
i am actually i am against
uh this idea that conservatives should
remove themselves from all these
platforms and then go gather in these
kind of conservative ghettos of these
like other
social media platforms that are made
just for conservatives where
no one's paying attention it's not
relevant no one cares what you say there
it's an echo chamber
and uh and not only is it like not
nearly as fun when there's nobody to
argue with but also it's just there's no
cultural purchase there there's no
relevance
uh so i'm against that i i think that
it's it's a good idea to be on these
platforms and to use that to spread a
message as long as we can now
if you get to the point on a platform
where you simply can't speak the truth
anymore it's just it's not allowed and
the only way to stay there is to abandon
the truth well then we shouldn't be on
the platforms anymore but we're not
quite there yet i mean i
for instance i can
what is a woman one of the reasons why
what is a woman was so successful and so
many people saw it is that we were able
to use these social media platforms to
promote it
which is which is a good thing because
then people were exposed to it or
otherwise wouldn't have been
so that's the issue i think
um when we talk about boycotts and
conservatives not
you know patronizing these world
companies i think that in particular
applies to products services content
whatever
where all we are is consumers
right
it's not a platform that we're using to
spread a message it's just something
that we're consuming and that's it
and especially where there are other
options so we could become consumers of
this woke company or in fact we could go
somewhere else
there's actually another option
it might take you know a little bit of
time to find it but but they are but
they are there
so that's what i'm talking about now
eventbrite
yeah it kind of falls in between i'll
admit it's um
it can be
it's not just a product or something
that we're consuming it is a platform
it could be a useful thing for getting
out a conservative message
except that now apparently you can't
so are we gonna keep using it that's
that's the point
gigasniper says matt i took someone out
on a date to watch what is a woman uh my
date told me i should start dressing
like you and that look is extremely
manly the flannels must return for the
sake of us men we need a strong manly
fit figure to lead us not erase us well
i'm here at least on fridays you have
that
until flannel friday becomes flannel
thursday and wednesday it could happen
uh courtney gross says matt if you want
a great kids show you need to watch
bluey yes it's on disney but i have not
yet yet come across anything that i'm
worried about regarding
leftist agenda propaganda its characters
are cute i find myself cracking up with
the humorous ways the parents handle
their two puppies i love it and i think
you will too
um yeah i've heard of bluey but wasn't
there a woke thing with blue i don't
know this but i i seem to remember there
being some
some recent story about wokeness
injected into this bluey show i could be
wrong but it's something to
look into
um
mark says matt a few days ago on your
show you seem to call into question the
notion of christian forgiveness i
appreciate you and your show but you do
not know more than jesus christ humble
yourself brother and remember who's in
charge
i don't claim to know more than jesus
but i do know what jesus said and i know
that he calls on us to forgive
those who persecute us
right you are
much like with compassion this is you
taking on the suffering of another if
you're if you're making someone else
take on the suffering it's not
compassion
uh same thing with forgiveness
you are called to forgive offenses
committed committed against you
if your brother offends you you should
forgive him seven times seven times
seven times and so on right if he
offends you
but if it isn't
you that's suffering the persecution or
the harm then it's not up to you to
forgive it and that was my point on
bringing this up a few days ago is that
is that sometimes christians will use
forgiveness as a cover for what is
really indifference or cowardice because
they don't want to get involved in a
situation so instead they say or there's
there's some sort of evil going on that
they don't want to denounce
and so instead they say i i i forgive i
forgive the person committing this evil
set up for you to forgive
someone else is falling victim to it
i think a particular example where this
came up was the the kids who are being
mutilated and butchered
by the gender affirmers
well it's not good enough for you to say
oh i forgive i forgive my enemies i
forgive them it's not you being
mutilated butchered it's the kids
so your forgiveness is worthless in that
case what does that even mean it's like
if if you uh
if someone stole your car
and you were upset about it and i came
up to you and i patted you on the
shoulder and i said hey man listen
i forgive the person who did this to you
what
of course yeah that's easy for you to do
this doesn't concern you
um that's a that is at best a very cheap
forgiveness
where you are not harmed you are not
concerned uh you were not persecuted
someone else was but you forgive them
no as i said that's to me that's uh
not forgiveness that's indifference and
there's certainly a difference
well if you thought the walrus gates uh
emotional roller coaster wasn't wild
enough i'm here to add
to the loops and corkscrews that tug of
violently at the heartstrings i've
received a letter from one of the
littlest members of the sweet baby gang
who
as i'm sure you can imagine is about one
of the millions of children traumatized
by the grave hostage situation involving
my giant walrut walrus i'll let the
child's solemn letter speak for itself
but i know that he speaks on behalf of
all mankind and all walrus kind so this
is a real it's actually a real letter
right before santos
uh it is real
dear mr matt i like your book
i hope mr ben gives you your walrus back
from uh eliana and my mom
from the mouth
of babes okay this is a child has spoken
out even the children are crying out
there you have it how far must this go
how long will some must i be tormented
how many children must be affected think
of the children
uh i still have not nor may i ever
receive my walrus but that should never
stop you from getting yours anyway go to
dailywire.com shop to bring home your
own johnny the walrus plushie and maybe
we can all
make this little sweet baby and eyes
dream come true also
here's the daily wire we're doing
everything we can to loosen the left
script on the culture we're making
movies that challenge woke hollywood
narratives documentaries like what is a
woman that exposed radical gender
ideology we're creating kids content
that parents can trust we can we even
sued the government over
unconstitutional mandates we're doing a
lot it's a lot of work and there's still
a long way to go but you can help in
just two simple steps one
stop shaving with your woke razor two
start shaving with jeremy's razors
[Applause]
hang on
if you're still not shaving with the
jeremy's razors chances are you're
funding left-wing agendas
we're building alternatives we're making
razors and the left is betting their
bottom billion dollars that you won't
use those alternatives prove them wrong
go to jeremysrazors.com
get your founders series shave kit today
daily wire plus members get 25 off
that's what you're getting jeremy's
razors shut up and shave now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
well even as big tech continues to
conspire to suppress my documentary what
is a woman most recently with
eventbrite's decision to ban all
screening events and watch parties from
their platform still the ideas from the
film and the question the ultimate
question are out there nothing can be
done now to stop that in fact the left
is finally beginning to realize that
they must come up with some kind of
answer they can't dodge it forever
that's why today for our daily
cancellation i want to take a take a
look at two of the most recent attempts
to answer and if not answer that at
least uh handle the great question of
our time what is a woman so we begin
with a man named matt ho who is um
running for senate in north carolina
on the green party platform matt was
very proud of himself a few days ago
when he tweeted this quote today i got
my first what is a woman question before
i could say anything my campaign manager
replied f off transphobe there was no
reason to say anything else hashtag f
off transphobe
trans rights are human rights
now as a green party candidate i must
admit it takes some guts to alienate 50
of your electoral base by cussing out
one person
still it's it's a rather sad thing to
see a grown man
proud of the fact that he had to dodge a
question that my three-year-old could
answer
perhaps next he'll brag about the time
when someone asked him whether the earth
is flat or round and he responded by
bursting into tears and running out of
the room
i mean these are moments of true courage
right
now i tried to explain to matt
that f off is not exactly a sufficient
answer to the question and to his credit
he he did give another attempt to
actually answer it
less to his credit his second attempt is
arguably even dumber than his first a
few hours later he tweeted this
for all the people demanding an answer
as to what is a woman
a woman is a person who identifies as an
adult female
trans rights are human rights
now look in a certain sense this is
progress
at least he's not attempting to define
the word woman by using the word woman
and yet this definition has its own very
significant problems because a female
person
is a human being who is of the nature to
bear offspring and who produces ova
which are female gametes or reproductive
cells so if someone identifies as female
then they are they are identifying as a
human capable of bearing offspring and
producing ova
but
a male who identifies as producing ova
still cannot produce ova he produces
sperm which are male gametes
no matter how he feels or what he says
or how he identifies he will produce
male reproductive cells all the same
therefore identifying as female when
you're male is no different in kind than
identifying as seven feet tall when
you're actually five and a half feet
tall
so what matt is claiming is is that
there is basically no difference
definitionally between an actual seven
foot tall human being and a human being
who's a foot and a half shorter but
views themselves as equal in height to
the seven foot person
but that's nonsense
i mean if it's true
that females are females
but then males can be females too
that means that females effectively
don't exist
and if they don't exist then it doesn't
make any sense to identify as one you
can only identify as that which can be
defined but if it can't be defined or
rather if it can be defined then there
must be a physical reality against which
your self-identification can be judged
accurate or inaccurate so if females
exist then males cannot be females and
if females do not exist then males also
cannot be females so no matter what you
do
males cannot be females
and matt ho is left up a creek without a
paddle
and nobody is even sending a search
party for him because nobody will know
that he's missing because he's a green
party candidate it's a terrible
situation all around
but if a politician on twitter
can't solve the riddle
maybe somebody on tiktok can
there's a video going around recently
gone viral from a user called circus
pork roast who uh
i mean that's her username
who believes that she has finally once
and for all
come up with the answer to the dreaded
question let's listen
i keep seeing all these clips from the
matt walsh documentary what is a woman
where he asks these you know gender
studies
experts what is a woman um and then when
they give him these like long carefully
thought out answers that like delve into
the identity and the complexities of you
know the label of woman um he basically
mocks them for not being able to give
him like a short concise
biologically truthful answer if you've
watched any of these clips and you
yourself have wondered i don't
understand why they can't just give like
a simple answer like it's such a simple
question um
i'm going to compare it to something
else and i'm going to ask you this
question what is a mother
can you tell me that in one sentence yes
i can uh thank you for asking mother is
a term that describes a woman's
relationship to her children
there you go that's what it means
hopefully we can all move on with our
lives now but i suspect that's not the
case
and you might say oh well obviously a
mother is someone who has given birth
and then raised children
um
but it's actually a lot more complicated
than that right um because yes there are
mothers who were pregnant and gave birth
to children and then raised those
children and we all agree those are
mothers but there's also people who
adopted children they didn't give birth
they were never pregnant but we still
consider them to be mothers because they
take on the societal role of mother and
they accept that as their role and then
there's also people who gave birth and
then gave those children up for adoption
and wanted nothing to do with them and
don't consider themselves to be mothers
um
are those
mothers do we consider those mothers as
well and then there's also people who
uh
were pregnant but had a miscarriage they
consider themselves to be mothers
but there are certain people who argue
against that and say well no your baby
was never born and therefore you're not
a mother and then there are people who
raise their nieces and nephews or their
grandchildren as their own children they
consider themselves to be mothers even
though they are also aunts or
grandmothers therefore taking on two
separate labels at once and both of
those things are true at the same time
and so as you can see a supposedly
simple question that seems to be rooted
in biological reality is actually much
more rooted in the societal roles that
people play and the labels that they
accept upon themselves and the same
thing is true of gender it's partially
rooted in biology but in our modern
times it's more so rooted in
the roles we play in society and the
labels we accept for ourselves
okay let's try our best to sort through
this first of all
nothing that you said there actually
makes the term mother confusing or
opaque as i already noted the word
mother describes a woman in relation to
her children a woman who gives birth to
offspring is a mother a woman who
conceives children who then tragically
die in utero is also a mother a woman
who adopts a child is a mother too
because that child once adopted is her
child what does it mean for him to be
her child well she's taking on the role
as his primary female caretaker she's
accepting a unique legal and moral
responsibility for and to the child she
is dedicating her life to him she's a
mother this is not confusing now there
is some nuance here sure a child who is
uh put up for adoption may end up with
in effect two mothers because the woman
who gave birth to him is a mother in the
biological sense while the woman who
adopts him is a mother in every other
sense this is why we often distinguish
in those situations between mother and
biological mother
again it's not really confusing you only
want to make it seem confusing because
you think it helps you make something
else seem confusing too and that brings
us to the second point
even if i agree that the word mother is
somehow vague or ambiguous which i don't
that still wouldn't at all prove that
the word woman is vague or ambiguous
there are there are ideas and concepts
that are difficult and hard to
define that doesn't make all ideas and
concepts difficult and hard to define
you can't prove that one word has no
objective definition simply by asserting
that some other word has no objective
definition this is what they they do all
the time well you asked me to identify
to define woman can you identify this
other word
what does that have to do with this word
we're talking about
so because one word can't be defined
that means no word can be defined
it's especially absurd in this case when
the other word mother
actually does have an objective
definition and everyone knows what the
word means
the reason why mother
has some extra complexity
is that it is a word which describes a
role and a relationship you're right
about that
but it's a role and relationship
specifically fulfilled by women
mother is a role that many women fill
but being a woman itself is not a role
or a relationship it is by definition a
physical biological identity
after all if mother is a role
and woman is a role
then who exactly is filling these roles
we can only say anything about mothers
at all if we first establish that women
exist and can be defined
there are plenty of other words that
describe roles that women play or
relationships they take part in sister
aunt girlfriend waitress actress etc all
of these
are roles that a woman can play
but even if on the margins there is some
element of ambiguity in some of these
roles
the roles can only exist and we could
only talk about them if women exist
first
and whatever ambiguity you can find in
the role does not at all even come close
to creating ambiguity around the concept
of womanhood itself
but all of this
could almost be put to the side because
here's the real question for you
whatever you think about
mothers
whatever you think about women
i ask you this
if a man with no children who isn't even
a caretaker of children like all he sits
at home all day playing video games he
doesn't he's not even he's not even
around children
if he stood up one day and declared that
he's a mother
would you accept that
self-identification as valid would you
say well i guess you're a mother too
in other words
if i agree that the word mother has some
complexity and nuance to it
does that mean that just anyone can
legitimately claim the title for
themselves does physical reality impose
no requirements at all on the person who
makes this claim
it may be difficult to wrap your arms
around all that the word mother
describes
but does that mean that it describes
nothing
does the word have a complex meaning or
no meaning
you're you're wondering whether an aunt
or a grandmother who's very close to a
child counts as a mother
but would you wonder whether my
five-year-old son counts as a mother
i assume you would not so you may
struggle with the concept around the
margins yet you know that the word means
something and it therefore excludes
people lots of people actually
regardless of what they say about
themselves or what anyone else says
about them
and if you would agree that the word
mother cannot be applied to just anyone
then you must agree that the word woman
cannot be applied to just anyone
that there is a reality
that the word describes both in the case
of women and mothers
and women who are mothers
there's a reality that it describes
which means that someone can
make a claim
can identify themselves and be wrong
about it because it does not comport
with the reality that the words are
supposed to describe
that's the real point that you should be
thinking about
and you'll have plenty of time to think
about it because you are today
on this first flannel friday
canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
we move on to our member segment hope to
see you there if not talk to you monday
godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you